okay so let's move on to the Wednesday
session so we'll be getting four
thoughts on the quantum algorithms today
and first we have Robin Kothari thanks
darling thank you all for coming and
thanks to the organizers for inviting me
all right so I'm gonna be talking about
some recent quantum algorithmic
primitives you've probably heard about
these on the first day maybe you've
heard the phrase a linear combination of
unitary zor-el see you methods maybe
your quantum signal processing and these
are just interesting quantum algorithmic
techniques that were discovered while
trying to look for algorithms for other
problems but they're just interesting
primitives that you might find useful in
your own research you know kind of like
phase estimation or amplitude
amplification you know whatever context
they were discovered in they're just
useful tools to have and so the
organizers asked me to speak about just
these primitives as a standalone so the
focus of this talk is just going to be
on these algorithmic techniques so I
won't tell you the the stories in which
these techniques were discovered so you
know like usually I talks at conferences
or even here you know something that
there's a topic that we're discussing
like Hamiltonian simulation or solving
linear equations on a point appear and
then you see the techniques in doing
that talk instead I'll just talk about
the techniques I'll tell you a little
bit about the application so it's kind
of like if you're reading a book with a
with a nice story like maybe it was
Republic or you watch the opera Das
Rheingold by Wagner or you watch Lord of
the Rings and you'll notice a literary
device of a ring that makes you
invisible so you could learn about
invisibility rings by reading all of
these stories or I can just tell you
about invisibility rings and tell you
they have applications in these three
stories so that's kind of what I'm
trying to do this in this talk I'll just
tell you about these techniques and I'll
see a little bit about the applications
but I just want to do it this way so
that if you see a problem that can be
solved by one of these primitives in
your own research you will be able to
apply it or you you at least ring a bell
and will be like oh yeah maybe I can
apply whatever
LCU methods ok alright so let me start
with these primitive so the primitives
I'm gonna be talking about are all gonna
be of this general format
you have some unitary that you know how
to implement on a quantum computer so
you have some quantum circuit or
whatever your some way of doing
something but you want to do something
else and you want to reduce this other
thing to this unitary that you know how
to do yeah and as I said I'm just going
to show you how the how these techniques
work you might you might find useful in
your research I won't focus too much on
like the technical details or proofs or
anything just high level ideas so that
you can recognize this when this comes
up in your own research
alright and let me start with the first
thing which is called oblivious
amplitude amplification which was
discovered in the context of Hamiltonian
simulation but you can use it elsewhere
and let me set the stage by talking
about something that I like to call a
probabilistic implementation of a
unitary so this is a scenario that might
come up which is you have a unitary V
that probabilistically implement another
unitary U and what I mean by that is
when you apply V on 0 to the MCATs I you
get a 0 to the M you qetsiyah so you get
supplied on cat's-eye plus some state
that's orthogonal to 0 to the M so if
you were to apply this unitary and then
measure the first n qubits if you see 0
to the M then you've applied to you
correctly so it's like you wanted to
apply you but you just have this kind of
crappy implementation of you it just
does you with probability P so P comes
from here so you know if you were to
measure the first time qubits you'll get
that with probability P another way of
thinking about what V does is like think
about the matrix for V and V has square
root of P times U and it's a top left
block so you have some not very good
implementation of a unitary you that you
desire and I'll call this kind of
implementation a probabilistic
implementation for obvious reasons or a
block encoding and this this phrase
block encoding the first of the fact
that this is a sub matrix or a block of
me
ok and the goal is I have V I want to
apply u so this is the framework as
talking right before you have something
but you want to do something else and
the question is how do you do this and
oblivious amplitude amplification is
going to be a technique for this so this
is a very general problem
as stated has nothing to do with
Hamiltonian simulation or solving linear
equations or any of the context and
which is used so it could come up
anywhere
and before describing oblivious
amplitude amplification let me tell you
other ways you could try to solve this
problem what's the most naive way to
solve this let's let's start with that
the simplest way to solve this is just
apply V on 0 to the MCATs I measure the
first time qubits see if that works if
it works that's great you have you cat
cat's eye on your second register if it
doesn't then throw everything away start
all over again so this is what I'll call
the classical repetition idea just apply
V measure the first register if you if
you see 0 to the M you're done that's
great otherwise repeat so what is the
cost of this procedure you only succeed
with probability P so you'll have to do
this one over P times you use 1 or P
uses of this unitary V the one that that
you have access to the one that's easy
to implement and you'll need one over P
copies of the interstate so this might
be problematic because you might not
have copies of the input state as I said
over here maybe you just have a circuit
for V and you want to apply you on some
arbitrary input States or somebody hands
if you don't really have copies of the
state so this may be about interrupt me
if there's any questions going too fast
or anything and yeah it's a very chill
talk I don't really have an agenda of
like promoting my results or anything
because these are all things from many
years ago so yeah I'm happy to take
questions at any point ok so that's one
thing you can do another thing you can
do anytime you can do something
probabilistically classically like you
can give a procedure that works with
some probability you can boost this with
amplitude amplification so this is the
second solution amplitude amplification
which is you repeat one over square root
of P times you apply V you reflect about
0 to the M you apply V dagger you
reflect about your starting state the
starting state is the state over here's
your to the MCATs I this is better in
terms of how many times it uses V and V
dagger it only uses a 1 over square root
of P times this is like the magic of
amplitude amplification you get a square
root speed-up but you also need a
reflection about the starting state this
state or equivalently just about cat's
eye again if you don't have copies of
the state or you don't have any way of
preparing the state you might not have
the ability to do this reflection if you
do this is great
I have a question if I if we do have
many copies of sigh can we use those to
implement the reflection you can but not
very accurately I think you'll need like
one over epsilon copies of site to
implement the reflection of our site of
precision epsilon so it's pretty badly
with precision as far as I know here you
need to be yeah you need to be pretty
small at least yeah like something like
one rupee because yeah so yeah if you
only have yeah that's probably true
although I'm not totally sure if it's 1
over epsilon or 1 over root epsilon this
is like just like an algorithm and one
assess large papers have you implemented
yeah so it's pretty bad so when I say
reflection about the state
when I say reflection about cat's eye I
mean do the operator identity minus 2
times cats like it's yeah 1 minus 2
times the projector to the state in
other words the state side will get
minus sign all the other states of
dongle directed will get a plus sign sir
so there's a classic amplification it
works great this is the cost
ok so oblivious amplitude amplification
was developed in the scenario where you
did not have copies of the input state
or the ability to reflect about the
input state now what do you do it's
clear that this technique doesn't work
because you need to do this so what we
do an oblivious amplitude amplification
is essentially the same thing except
just don't reflect about catch size just
apply V deflector bar 0 to the M apply V
dagger to reflect about 0 to the M and
this is a bit like well we had an
algorithm that worked and there was a
step that we were not able to do and
we're like well just let's just cross
out that step because that's really hard
to do and you know
life is hard I want something easy but
it actually works so this is one of
those things that sounds too good to be
true but it really works and the reason
it works is this inside this lock is
unitary or is a scalar multiple of unit
of a unit area this was not unitary this
would not work but the other techniques
that I talked about would still have
worked if you know you can always do you
can do amplitude amplification even if
this part was not unitary you can do
classical repetition but oblivious and
amplification really exploits the fact
that this block is unitary but I'm not
gonna prove this as I said I won't focus
on really technical details during this
talk I just want to explain if you
encountered this kind of scenario where
you have this kind of probabilistic
implementation of unitary think
oblivious amplitude amplification then
yeah if you want the technical details
you can google it you'll be able to find
it so this is really nice let me just
say that a little cleaner yeah so there
are some subtleties here right like for
instance do you need to be to the
independent loops ayat
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah well when I say
this yeah like it's a you know maybe I
guess the P the P is just it's just a
number P like it doesn't depend on sight
yeah it's the same P for all so it's you
know if you think of the unitary being
looking at this it's just some scalar
written outside that's true well yeah
exactly
well in my way of thinking about it then
that that operator is not unitary
because it has when you write it as a
block like this because you'll have
different coefficients for different
size so that's not that's not good
enough yes it has to be this kind of
implementation with some probability P
that does not depend on sy and that's
really where what's being exploited by
we're oblivious to the input state
because after an application requires
you to know the input state because it
refers you to do a reflection about the
interstate and you're oblivious to this
you don't need you I don't know but
that's exactly what I'm talking about
these things at this generality so that
somebody here will think of good
connections to things that they work on
yeah cuz otherwise you will find this
buried on page 47 of a Hamiltonian
simulation paper that you will probably
not read so okay so you will find it in
there's no reference on this okay you'll
find it in our paper on hamiltonian
simulation which was called exponential
improvement in precision for simulating
hamiltonians it was like the first
Hamiltonian simulation paper that had a
log 1 over epsilon dependence on
precision as opposed to all the previous
ones which it's the one so much like
it's me Dominic and your child's Richard
cleave and Rolando sama
a one-line idea I guess it's yeah I
guess the one-line idea maybe would be
if you're familiar with them this
Marriott Watrous technique for boosting
qma the idea is that somehow when you
make a when you let's say we just make
this measurement and you get this bad
state the bad state doesn't you're not
lost like the back state actually has
everything you want about the good state
and you always remain in a two
dimensional subspace so even though you
think all hope is lost actually on a two
dimensional subspace if we can just do a
reflection and come back to getting some
probability on the good state you're
fine this is where unitarity is being
exploited that you remain in this
dimension
more precisely as Arnold was saying if
this was not unitary you'd have many
different to 2d blocks and you'd be
rotating at different speeds in
different blocks and things would go
back but this is kind of the idea so
it's kind of the same at its heart the
same ideas in married waters would like
to do yeah yeah I'll give you an
application maybe in a while because I
need to develop another technique before
I can describe an application I'm
thinking that you have a circuit
description of V so V dagger is just
take that circuit and like dagger the
whole circuit yeah
replace every element with a dagger yeah
okay so this is a Bolivia sample
identification it's yeah it's cool it's
useful as I said it's super important
that you is unitary or close to unity
that there's a robust version of this
that works when he was absent plus the
Unitarian things work out as you might
expect with something some lost that
depends on epsilon okay yeah so this is
a cake home summary for a Bolivian
amplitude amplification if you have a
probabilistic implementation of a
unitary you can convert that to like a
legit actual implementation of the
unitary if he was not unitary the best
thing I know is to use regular Absalon
close then you'll get something at the
end that's epsilon close or some
function of epsilon close so you know
these these techniques are all like
they're continuous like they're not
they're not brittle that they would
working exactly if you is entertaining
if it's likely nonunitary like the
circuit explorers or something like the
circular so do something reasonable and
there's a version of this theorem that
deals with this like it exactly analyzes
this maybe that version is not in our
stock paper that's in our follow-up it's
okay it's you can ask me or Dominic
later on for references there's it's
kind of spread across the literature
okay so that's all I wanted to say
oblivious amplitude amplification in
fact it's it's such a useful algorithmic
primitive it's been implemented natively
in the Q char programming language
here's the documentation so that's how
useful it is it's in the programming
language yeah so you can try to use it
okay so that's that's all I wanted to
say about oblivious amplitude
amplification let me tell you about
another interesting idea the linear
combination of interface you've probably
heard this maybe you heard the phrase
LCU methods on the first day people
talked about this quite a bit okay this
is another this one is a much simpler
idea then oblivious sampled
ramifications nothing really mysterious
going on but it's just something to keep
at the back of your mind that this is
something you can do which is so this is
the this is a problem you have some
matrix B that's represented as a linear
combination of easy-to-implement unitary
so again this is at the same form and
there's something that's easy here the
things that are easier WI so you have
you know how to implement this unitary
is WI in fact they're so easy that you
also are able to implement this kind of
controlled WI operator which is in the
first register it takes an index I in
the second register it will apply the
unitary WI for you
you know if each WI is a polynomial size
circuit and the total number of indices
is polynomial then you you can also
implement this with a polynomial size
circuits it's not a completely
unreasonable assumption but this is what
I formerly mean by the w i's are
individually easy that you can apply
them in this format but you want to
implement B all these problems are w i's
are easy you want to implement B so what
do you do and let me just start with an
example so let's say B is just the sum
of two unitary is W 0 plus W 1 and you
want to implement B here's a procedure
that probabilistically implements B so
it doesn't actually implement B but it
probabilistic lis implements B in the
sense of what I was talking about so you
wanna apply B to some given input state
cat's-eye so you want produces let's say
if B were unitary then you actually want
to apply it if B were not unitary then
let's say you want to apply it but now
I'll give you reflections about the
inputs there's something I have to give
you something because you won't be able
to
was not unitary so it's not even yeah
that just means I want you to produce
yeah like I want you to produce this
steak B cat's-eye divided by the non
right appropriately scaled state if it's
not Unitarian if it's unitary I really
want you to do the right thing okay but
I'm gonna give you a procedure that
doesn't do either of these things that
does something worse which is it gives
you a probabilistic implementation like
I was talking about a couple slides ago
and this is really easy to do there's
nothing deep going on over here let's
and I'll just give an example with B
equal to W zero plus W want all you do
is you start out with a plus state in
the first register ket signed the second
register and apply the select W operator
you'll get this superposition and just
collecting the plus state here you'll
get W zero plus W once I and minus state
over here minus W once I and W zero plus
W 1 is B so if you if you look at this
operator now this is a probabilistic
implementation of B in the sense that if
you measure the first qubit you see a
ket plus then you have B sy if you don't
you have the other guy so this friction
of the framework I was talking about
previously probabilistic implementation
so it's like a crappy implementation of
B but it's something and now you can
boost it using the techniques I talked
about before more generally this will
work even if it's not just the sum of
two unit Ares and it's like an arbitrary
so I'm like this mmm
the circuit is a little more complicated
but it's not more generally what will
happen is you'll get a unitary V that
block encodes B divided by the one norm
of all of these coefficients this is the
full algorithm if you care it's like you
start out with a state which is like the
sum of square roots of the coefficients
apply that on the state you'll get it
it's it's the same idea as the previous
one like if you understood the idea with
two unit today's it's just a
straightforward generalization you just
try it out it works and you get a
probabilistic implementation of B so
this is a really simple idea there's
nothing deep going on you can work this
out in like five minutes just that if
you have unit Ares WI that you know how
to do you have some matrix be
represented as a linear combination
these guys then you can come up with a
unitary that block encodes this guy with
some scaling factor we do I Fourier
transform the first register
things together I have a psalm of eyes
then for each I conditioned on it I
applied up user by yes you get the mixed
up yeah because I'm collecting all the
collecting the state kit at a upfront
it's a bit like I measure in the kadhi
kadhi per basis yeah so that mixes it
Amal
exactly it's like a it's like a programs
but but with these weights to get the
weights right yeah if all the way to
uniform then dub it exactly that's right
that could be hard yeah so that's part
of the problem like that's like some
unit Ares B will be easy some unit Ares
B will be hard and they will depend on
how hard it is to create this
coefficient state it's this guy we've
already assumed is easy so this will
really be the source of most of your
problems how hard is it implement this
also this this this coefficients will
define how how badly you've implemented
in the sense of how low is the
probability so the alphas will come in
two different places like they'll define
your probability and they'll also define
how hard it is for you to create this
day so it works exactly it's the best of
both worlds if B is unitary you can use
oblivious amplification he's not unitary
than well of course you can't but then
you should use regular amplitude
replication I suppose and I'll give you
an example of this this is why I waited
till now because I wanted to develop
this machinery before I talked about
applications of oblivia sample dynamic
same question okay okay so let me get
right down to the application then I'll
give you two applications when using LCU
plus oblivious amplification and one
using LCU plus just regular amplitude
there so you can see both ways in which
it can be used okay here's a take-home
message for linear combination ureters I
think I've driven this point home which
is this if you have an operator that's a
linear combination unit race then you
can express
then you can probabilistically implement
it then later on use either oblivious or
regular after the application to get it
an actual implementation okay so let me
give you the first application with
vacations that you have pay independent
of side may not be satisfied here
because the normalization constant could
depend on right on side know if B is
unitary then the normalization constant
right exactly so if B is unitary you can
use oblivious Hamid okay if it's not
then you can yeah yeah so let me give
you an application so let me start with
an application where B is unitary so
that's to the to the Hamiltonian
simulation problem so I won't describe
this problem in great detail but you're
just giving a local Hamiltonian which is
H a sum of terms H J and you want to
implement this unitary so it's just a
simple three-step process to applying
these methods what you want to do is you
want to express the unity that you want
to perform the target unitary as a
linear combination of unitary that you
know how to perform right so this is a
framework I've been talking about so
first let's start with something simpler
let's express H as a linear combination
of unitary as we know how to perform
this is easy this is almost given to us
because it's given to us as a sum of
local terms HT acts on some constant
number of qubits that's what a local
Hamiltonian is so just write out HJ in
the poly basis let's say on these local
pieces this is some constant number of
terms you'll have some constant number
of gates that's fine the Polly's are
unitary that's the interesting part but
that's the important part about poly
that's why I said use the poly basis now
you've written H as a sum of unitary
matrices all the integers are tensor
products of Powys they'll have some
coefficients so it's a linear
combination of Poly's Salina communities
that's fine but that's just H what we
want is this unitary e to the minus IHT
but that works out just fine too so if H
is some linear combination of pollings
like this just write out a Taylor series
for e to the minus IHT which is this is
just a Taylor series and this is the
expansion and you will observe that each
term is actually just this whole thing
is just a linear combination of unitary
and why is that this is identity that's
the unitary this is obviously a linear
combination of en phase this is a
product of two linear combination
immunities and so each term in the
product is also just a product of unit
Ares with some coefficient and so on so
now we've expressed the operator that we
want as a linear combination of unitary
is that's great the operator that we
want is actually unitary
so now you can apply linear combination
of your choice and oblivious amplitude
amplification because it is unitary so
that's great this is this is the full
algorithm for Hamiltonian simulation
this is where the robustness comes in
because this this door will have a
truncated at some point the Taylor
series has excellent convergence so
we'll just truncate it after a few steps
and you'll get very good at our
dependence this is the source of the log
1 or epsilon scaling in all the newer
Hamiltonian simulation origins the fact
that these series converge so fast so
it'll be an extremely precise
approximation to the unitary but it will
not be strictly unit a so that's why you
need a slightly robust version of oh
just because I wanted to take the
simplest case of a local Hamiltonian
simulation that people who care about
but in theory you could also have a
Hamiltonian that's a sum of tensor
products of Poly's that act on all of
your qubits then this would work just
fine yeah just this is the simplest
scenario if local Hamiltonian machine so
much but yeah you can generalize it
pretty straightforwardly
let's see the away what do you mean like
what is the like how many times you have
to like what is this probability so so
the way we let me give you this light I
have a reference okay the way we
implement here this is this this
algorithm sometimes called the truncated
Taylor series algorithm the way we
implemented here the the probability
will just be a constant so instead of
doing Hamiltonian simulation for the
entire time T we do it for a very small
time T so that that step just costs some
constant amount of time so you'll only
actually do like three reflections with
the Bolivia's amplification and you'll
get an extremely precise simulation of e
to the IH t divided by some R and then
we'll just paste this block R times to
get the full simulation each piece is
very small yes you do but because these
pieces are really small the the l1 norm
of the beta's will just be some constant
because it's like it'll be like e to the
I some small constant so that the l1 no
no that is like e to the some constant
that's some constant
so you can take the constant as small as
you want because Hamiltonian simulation
can always be broken up into smaller
problems so e to the i HT can always be
viewed as doing e to the IH T divided by
our the whole to the power R exactly so
we choose the concert in such a way that
this small piece is basically something
like a unit time simulation it's not
really unit time it's more like unit
will divided by T and also by the total
number of terms in the Hamiltonian so
it'll work out that each constant each
piece just takes some fixed amount of
resources and then you'll just have to
do this a number of times that depends
on T and the number of terms in your
think of decomposing the whole problem
to just problem of doing a small block
and you just copy paste the block many
times in each block you'll use of livius
and program there's only like three
times or something but overall you've
used it like linearly in the number of
terms plus times time so that'll be time
times the number of terms of your
Hamiltonian that's the that's how much I
split it yeah any other questions about
this
okay so let me just quickly mention
another application that doesn't use
oblivious amplitude amplification
because the operator you're trying to do
is knock unity and that's the quantum
linear systems algorithm so here you're
given some hermitian matrix a and some
state B and you want to implement a
universe time on can't be correctly
normalized and again so here what is the
easy to simulate unitary a is hermitian
so you can think of a as a Hamiltonian
so you can think of e to the IAT as
something that's easy because of like
well the previous slide there's an
algorithm for doing Hamiltonian
simulation so that's the easy to
simulate unities and now you want to
express the unitary that you want to do
or not the unitary the operator that you
want to do a inverse as a linear
combination of these guys and you can do
it and we give an explicit decomposition
in this paper and now you're done you've
expressed the operator do you want as a
linear combination of operators that you
have apply linear combination of unitary
it's not this guy is not unitary so you
have to apply regular amplitude
amplification so you'll need the ability
to reflect about the starting state but
that's a feature of all linear systems
algorithms they all have yes this is
this thing and in fact as much better
error dependence the original HL
algorithm had a 1 over epsilon scaling
whether this one gives you log 1 or
epsilon kind of because this this one
has the series that we write down as
much better error conversions in this
version of the problem if you're using
app identification yeah you'll need you
need to be able to reflect about instead
one copy I don't think so because the
thing you're trying to do is not unitary
so it's you have to use measurement and
sometimes you'll just lose your state
but you can do it given copies of be
like then don't use amplitude
amplification just use classical
repetition like the alphas don't depend
on a the Alpha is just some property if
it's some property of the function X
inverse and fully analysis like it's
just some kind of like here it's not
something nice but it could be it could
have been like some chebyshev home as a
Bessel function or something it is what
is it it's not the Bessel functions but
it's something like that it's just some
property of how easy it is to represent
the function X inverse as a linear
combination of sines and cosines that
kind of thing exactly because you can't
literally represent this function as a
linear combination these guys because i
zero it blows up so in this in all of
these linear systems argument you assume
something with the condition number
which tells you that no eigenvalues very
close to zero and that'll tell you
exactly how you do this decomposition
and you can do that in this paper we we
give two different ways of doing it one
is where you just think of this as a
black box sometimes you might have
Hamiltonian simulation available as a
black box that didn't go through the
previous algorithms like maybe you used
a different way to do a Hamiltonian
solution so then this will release you
that in a black box manner but you can
do it less black box later and we do it
that way as well in this paper so we
give two different solutions here I
thought this one is the easiest way to
explaining following for the previous
slide okay so maybe that's all I wanted
to say about how you use these methods
and there's also other applications of
these LCA methods to solving
differential equations preparing keep
States solving SDP is Hamiltonian
simulation for other kinds of Hamilton's
as Ryan was asking you can do other
interesting Hamiltonian simulation
techniques with this anyway I won't say
anything about that and let me move on
to the last thing that I was gonna say
so so have like 12 minutes I got a lot
of questions during the talk so maybe
I'll going to the part that was formerly
reserved for the questions but I guess
this is pretty flexible so the last
thing I want to say is quantum signal
processing again same kind of thing you
have some unitary that you know how to
do you want to implement a unitary
that's different from the one that you
know how to do so you want to do W this
is its eigen decomposition
that's immunity W you have a circuit for
it but what you want to do is some
function of W but and what I mean by a
function of W is it's a function of its
eigenvalues f and let's say f is a
continuous time
if it's a very reasonable function let's
say I'm going to any of these technical
details so exactly what I want so for
example let's say if fw were diagonal
you know w looks like this but i want to
implement the operator a that looks like
that this is a reasonable thing that
might happen you you know this is not
totally unreasonable because some of
your job is already done for here
somebody's already given you a unitary
that's diagonal in the same basis of the
operator that you want to implement so
that's often a difficult thing in common
you know you if you work with Basie's
and so on so that part is done for you
the basis is right just the eigenvalues
are wrong you just have to fix the
eigenvalues again it's the same as
before if they if they if this is a
function that again gives you back a
unitary then that's great then you'll be
able to do it better you won't need
reflections about the starting C and so
on if not you will still get something
but it would be probabilistic like you
so exactly covers both cases so this is
a scenario you might encounter this
happens actually all the time I'll give
you some concrete examples or when this
happens but just just to get warmed up
so for example let's say you want to
implement the function of e to the I
theta which is just e to the I theta to
the power K so can you do that for some
integer K so that's easy you just
applied WK x this is a very simple
example where all you want to do the
eigen
jacent of our case they just apply w k
times w something that's easy so then
it's not easy right right so depending
on yeah if if all you have is just some
circuit for w then yeah all you can do
is this for polynomial time okay more
interesting functions what about f of e
to the I theta is theta inverse this is
actually exactly the thing that happens
in linear system solvers because you
have Hamiltonian simulation which can do
e to the I a for you for some your
matrix a but you wanted a inverse so if
you can solve this problem then now you
can use one of single processing to do
linear to do the linear system solver
you don't have to use the other
techniques I talked about for the last
couple minutes another example is what
if you want to do F of e to the I theta
is e to the I cosine of theta and now it
looks like I just put a crazy function
over here just to just to demonstrate
that something crazy can happen cosine
inverse that's even worse but actually
this arises in Hamiltonian simply this
is a very natural thing that happens
look for example implementing the square
root of unity you can also do that with
quantum single processing so it's a very
general procedure and let me say okay so
there's a kind of stuff that you might
want to do I'm not really going to talk
about application I just want to
motivate that this is a problem that
actually people face so okay so what do
you do so let's get rid of this so what
can you do so one thing you can do which
is a pretty general thing to do
so some solutions to this problem are
you can use phase estimation on W so you
take your input state do face estimation
so you get some approximation of the
phase and then you apply this function
on the phase try to put it as a
coefficient this will always have poor
scaling with epsilon the the precision
because phase estimation to distinguish
eigenvalues are epsilon close you have
to go you have to use like one over
epsilon repetitions of faces are like
the cost is one over epsilon so this
will work but it often has poor scaling
his position often many of the
applications that I talked about in the
previous slide like Hamiltonian
simulation and and linear system solvers
were first solved using phase estimation
and you can do it and you have you have
papers that
exactly that only later on was a
discovered that we can use these more
more interesting techniques of a better
precision scaling another thing you can
do is just use linear combination of
immunity's the stuff I've been talking
about the last 20 minutes try to
represent this function as a polynomial
if it's a continuous function you'll at
least be able to approximate it as a
polynomial so you'll be able to write a
as some linear combinations of W and
powers of W so that's fine and you can
do this and again there's many if
there's papers before quantum signal
processing was discovered this is
exactly what we did and we have papers
that do this eigenvalue transformation
at the LCU
in fact this is just the same album that
I talked about on the previous slides
and the third solution which is often
superior to using linear combination
unit rates is this thing called quantum
signal processing I don't talk about
forward like the next two slides or so
and this was developed by a long hollow
and electron and okay I'm just gonna
give you a rough idea of how this works
so this is the problem statement just
remember that you have some you want to
eigenvalue transformation you have some
unitary but i can really go wrong you
don't want them you want something else
that's like the take-home message of
quantum single processing but I'll just
say a few things about exactly how it
works and the way it works is consider
the following operator which is W which
was easy think of the controlled version
of W so if you have a circuit for W you
can always create the controller version
of W so that's fine so control W has the
following feature on ket 0 times some
eigenvector just it does nothing and on
cake 1 times an eigen vector it puts the
correct eigen value over here and
returns the eigenvector so if we only
look at this operator are restricted to
first qubit where the second qubit is
guaranteed the second register is
guaranteed to be an eigenvector then
control W is this this operators it's 1
0 0 e to the I theta
so just looking at what control maybe
this picture will help actually yeah
this is control W and here if I put in
an eigenstate of W this is the phase
kickback trick yeah the on this qubit
you will see this this unitary 1 0 0 e
to the I say that and now what I'm going
to do is I want to take control W and
single qubit unitary is applied to this
on this cubed and interleave them so I'm
going to do a circuit of this format
something will keep it unitary control w
single cubed unit is control W single so
on and I'm gonna ask the question what
what 2 by 2 matrix do you get over here
so if I did only control W you'd get 1 0
0 e to the I theta this is some to
weight to unitary and there's a product
of many of them so you'll get some four
numbers here in this unitary matrix and
they'll all be functions of theta that
was the that was the only free parameter
and the question is what kinds of
functions can you get maybe more
formally this matrix is just a product
of U 0 a 2 by 2 unitary times
the control W operator times u 1 times
control W around till u K minus 1
control W ok and I just want to answer
this like purely mathematical question
of like taking products or matrices of
this form what kind of 2x2 matrix can I
get so that's the question now there's
just like a math question that I want to
solve and essentially this quantum
signal processing technique fully
answers this question it gives you a
full characterization of what kind of
matrices you can get like this and why
would we be interested in this
characterization because if you can get
this matrix to be of this format f e to
the I theta something something
something then we're done because this
will give you a a a probabilistic
encoding or a block encoding of the
function that you want to do so you
started out with something which I going
about the e to the I theta now you get
some matrix that for the eigenvectors
theta has eigen value f of e to the I
theta so this is exactly a block
encoding off the operator that you want
and if you can obtain it
then you're in great shape you can apply
this technique then you can play
whatever depending on whether f is
unitary or not maybe you might not be
able to do this perfectly you might do
this with some probability and so on but
having a full characterization of what
kinds of things can you obtain is really
crucial and this is one of the key
technological things that you get from
this quantum si
in framework and because I'm running
overtime maybe all that that's maybe all
I wanted to say about quantum signal
processing is that if you have some
unity you know how to do you want to
apply some function to its eigenvalues
and the function is somewhat reasonable
then you can often do it with quantum
signal processing what's reasonable okay
so maybe else okay let me just state a
I'll state a formal feed on that like
and hopefully little help this was just
gonna be my recap slide this was the T
techniques introduced but let me go to
okay so I was working with this unitary
which was like 1 0 0 e to the I theta
that's like a reflection about that's a
that's a rotation about the z basis but
it's gonna be or up to a global face but
it's gonna be a little more convenient
to work with a rotation about the X
basis so and so that guy let's take this
unitary which is X I 1 minus x squared 1
by X square X so by the way all of this
comes from this recent paper of under
skillion you on su Kwong Harlow and
Nathan weeb so let's take this guy and
now I'm gonna have a full
characterization of what kind of unitary
is gonna get if I now they don't take
arbitrary unit Ares for the other guys
for the u 0 u 1 u 2 and so on but it's
it's just again reflections about see
it's a slightly smaller space if you
turns out it's everything that's all you
need for most applications so this this
kind of theorem gives you a full
character you know what kind of two by
two matrices can you get if you
interleave multiplication between some
two by two unitary this guy two by two
unitary this guy this guy and so on for
K times you'll get some matrix like this
and there's some obvious things you can
say which is like these things have to
be polynomials of degree K in the
variables that appear in this matrix
which you only multiply them K times and
so on this guy has to be a degree K
minus 1 this is just stuff you can see
and like the parodies have to be correct
because you multiply them a certain way
and this comes from the fact that this
matrix is unitary and so on and it turns
out that these totally reasonable
conditions are also if and only if so in
other words the thing that really
matters is the degree of this polynomial
that appears over here because this
degree will dictate how many times you
have to apply W operator so what you
want to do is you want to represent the
function that you care about as a low
degree polynomial that's also it's also
a bounded polynomial and it approximates
your function
I hope that helped okay okay
the singer pricing then you need to
implement a control W I guess that's
right
they are look yeah I don't actually know
it's an area where that happens okay
yeah I guess that could be a problem
here sometimes their techniques to
create control wrw like if you know and
I can you know I think it's like a video
result which explains how given only a
cup a black box for W and if you know it
one of its eigenvectors let's say you
know the catch kid zero is an
eigenvector you can and you know what
eigenvalue using that you can create a
controlled version of W a completely
black box way but this requires you to
know an eigenvector and its eigenvalue
so it's not general sometimes you can
doing existed do you now use
approximation theory because I do I want
to implement some given target unitary I
wanted I need to know like what degree
probably Gnomeo approximately represents
that function over the domain of
interest yeah that's right so for some
things you yeah you look for you you
often have to use approximation CA often
be sure polymers will pop up that kind
of thing but always you might also hear
more about this in the remaining stalks
of the day right okay well you also be
talking about this maybe I - one stands
for a person he's an expert on quantum
signal processing
you can adapt you what it's the only one
even a rogue colony so there's their
subtleties and many interesting things
oh this is just saying that this matrix
is unity like this this this column this
row has norm one like this squared plus
this squared is one that's just a this
is a basic condition for this to even be
a unitary matrix how do you get the
Phi's okay so that's a whole different
can of worms so it's actually pretty
hard to do this theorem just tells you
these exist how do you find them in
theory there's maybe a polynomial time
algorithm there was a certain in the
original paper but it's actually very
hard to flip it in practice and you know
recent paper like andrew childs and
co-authors they try to implement this
and they could only go up to like very
low degree polynomials because what you
need to do is very high precision route
finding of high degree polynomials and
this in theory is polynomial time but is
actually hard to do so there's some
caveats that make this totally useful
right off the bat instead of trying to
find this file just fix them to be
something to say
obviously you fix all these files then
you'll just get some two-by-two matrix
that's completely determined by the face
like the face of the only free
parameters so if you fix them you'll get
some two-by-two matrix which may not be
your function and then you'll just be
implementing the wrong function it's
crucial like this is your only freedom
then you it's crucial that you pick
these coefficients in such a way that
you actually get the function that
you're trying to implement like I want
this guy for example to be F of e to the
I theta you get something that's just
not the thing you want it
okay so it's time to want to mix up so
that's they thanks